So today I want to explore
the problem that we face,
which is much more than a dilemma.
I'd say quad lemon in a in a way,
or a quit lemme have a,
how we manage our future energy demands,
uh,
and how we invest our resources
in alternative forms of energy.
And I'm going to spend most
of this session talking about,
uh,
the,
the possibilities and
limitations of nuclear power.
And this will provide a foundation for,
uh,
the lecture on next Tuesday,
which will be,
uh,
particularly directed at wind,
but,
uh,
more broadly at renewables.
So first I'd like to,
uh,
have you considered the distribution of
nuclear power plants in the world and
really reflect on where
they're not located.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they're high concentration,
particularly in the eastern
Midwestern part of the United States,
uh,
but also in Europe.
So within the u s you see that a,
they're really concentrated
up in the northeast,
uh,
but also a south and a nearby Chicago.
And California is quite striking in that,
uh,
in 1976 of the state of California enacted
a moratorium against new new nuclear
power plant development.
If you look more closely,
uh,
at,
Europe,
uh,
and particularly it at France,
you can see a very high dependence in
some nations in the European Union on
nuclear power.
France now receives approximately 75%
of its power from nuclear plants and
inside the United States also,
there's quite a bit of variability
and reliance on nuclear.
Uh,
so in Connecticut,
for example,
uh,
on nearly a 65% of the power
that we consume in the state,
it comes from nuclear
nuclear plants in Niantic,
which is about a 45
miles to the east of us,
uh,
on the Thames River from the
millstone nuclear power plants.
So it's a quite curious how
different parts of the country,
different,
uh,
economies have,
treated nuclear power,
uh,
and explaining the cultural predisposition
to accept the risks and accept the
costs,
uh,
is not an easy thing to do.
So just so you have an overview of,
of,
uh,
the status of the nuclear
industry in the world.
There are about 434 and 36
different reactors that are
operating in 30 different
countries.
Uh,
50 reactors are now under construction,
uh,
mostly in Asian nations.
Uh,
and within the U S,
uh,
there are proposals for 20 new reactors.
And of these four to eight,
maybe online in 2020,
uh,
China has 11 online at present
with 22 under construction.
And as a nation where nuclear
development is most rapid in the world,
uh,
within the u s,
the operating licenses that have had,
uh,
limits placed on them
of a operating licenses,
uh,
between 30 and 40 years.
Uh,
most of these are going to be
granted operating extensions.
And the concern was that the plant or
the infrastructure would not have the
capability of,
of lasting longer than
40 years at the outside,
but they're finding that,
uh,
the,
engineering integrity of
many of the plants is higher
than they thought it might
be a,
but,
uh,
this basically is,
is a,
uh,
a short term lease on,
on the problem of decommissioning
these nuclear plants.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
what we'll be talking
about in a few moments,
uh,
which will be the problem
of managing a nuclear waste.
The MIT report,
the faculty report that was issued in
2003 and then recently updated that we've
asked you to read,
uh,
has some really,
I think important lessons and
conclusions and better within a,
so they concluded that
after five years from 2003,
so this is two years ago,
no new plants are under
construction in the United States,
and insufficient progress has
been made on waste management.
The sober warning is
that if more is not done,
nuclear power will diminish as a practical
and timely option for climate change
risk mitigation.
So as one thinks about,
uh,
what our options are,
particularly coal as opposed
to investments in renewables,
uh,
as opposed to investments
in nuclear power.
You know,
one,
one might think about it as
a problem of relative cost,
uh,
but you also might think about a relative
risk and ease of bringing a additional
capacity online.
I'll give him,
given the different sources.
Uh,
and underlying this I think is a,
a,
an under,
uh,
underestimated a cultural factor,
which is a,
what we worry about in the United
States and our predisposition,
uh,
to,
remember,
uh,
not just Chernobyl,
but also what happened
at Three Mile Island.
And in 1979,
the capital costs of constructing
a new plant or are often enormous,
uh,
and because so much can go wrong,
including,
uh,
construction delays that can
cause interest rates to rise and,
and,
uh,
the amount that has to be paid
back to investors to rise.
It's caused,
what's a thought of as a risk premium
being put on investment funds.
So a banks or private investment
companies often will loan the money to a
utility company that wants
to build a new plant,
but they will do so at a higher rate
when it's measured by a kilowatt hour.
And,
uh,
so there's about a 2 cent per kilowatt
hour difference between nuclear,
uh,
compared to coal and natural gas,
which makes this a very,
very expensive proposition.
Basically the money costs more.
Uh,
the leg,
a legal and regulatory structure that
surrounds a nuclear power is a rather
complex,
uh,
the,
initial statute that govern,
uh,
what,
now exists was the atomic energy act back
in 1954 that we discussed a bit during
the beginning of the term when we were
talking about the atmospheric weapons
testing.
But you know,
recall that the technology that the,
the science and Engineering
Foundation for nuclear power plants,
it really evolved out of the
nuclear weapons development program.
Uh,
so many of the nuclear power plants,
uh,
that,
were the earliest versions,
uh,
say at Hanford,
or at a Oak Ridge in Tennessee.
Uh,
these plants were first generation,
but they were designed predominantly,
uh,
to provide enriched
fuel for atomic weapons.
This defines both state and
federal authority concerning
nuclear nuclear energy.
Uh,
and it really,
uh,
was the,
the watershed that,
that,
uh,
ended the monopoly,
the government monopoly
on nuclear technology.
And it gave the private sector
a role in nuclear development,
uh,
and it expressly prohibited states
from any role in transfer delivery,
receipt acquisition,
possession or use a of nuclear materials.
And it also gave the
Atomic Energy Commission,
uh,
the exclusive authority
to manage these issues.
Uh,
and what,
what is interesting about the history of,
of the AEC is that they were both
the promoters of the technology,
the developers of the technology,
uh,
and they were supposed
to be the regulators.
So the,
uh,
the Fox watching the hen house,
so to speak,
and,
uh,
this was recognized,
quite early in the history of the AEC
when Congress decided to break off the
responsibilities
associated with regulation,
uh,
to,
have a higher probability of safety
and environmental protection,
uh,
and worker safety,
so that the nuclear regulatory commission
was given these responsibilities.
So this is an independent agency now that,
uh,
has commissioners assigned to it that
make choices about issuing licensing
decisions and about,
uh,
safety violations or
environmental violations,
uh,
associated with the industry so that a
states have retained the authority over
electric power generation
sale and transmission.
And another aspect of,
of the development of
the nuclear industry,
which is important to know,
uh,
is that,
this is not being protected by
private insurance companies.
Uh,
the price Anderson nuclear industry's
Indemnity Act really holds the industry
harmless,
uh,
from damage claims in the
event of a serious accident.
And it also sets up a procedure for
compensation or that has criteria that are
really pretty clear,
uh,
that,
the,
those that claim damage
have to show what it was.
They have to calculate
their monetary loss.
Uh,
and they also have to
demonstrate causality,
uh,
that,
is,
uh,
you know,
route relatively easy to demonstrate in
this case because of a specific isotope
mixed your signature that
would come from any sort of a,
a,
a nuclear explosion or,
or an accident.
So the nuclear regulatory
commission was created in 1974.
Now,
you can imagine also that,
uh,
many states,
might be more worried about
nuclear power than a other states.
And California is really a
pretty good example of that.
So that,
uh,
the 1976,
the state of California created a
moratorium on new nuclear power plant
construction.
Uh,
so states might have the
authority to do that.
Uh,
and until the federal government
approved a methods to dispose of,
of high level waste,
uh,
the state of California was
really quite concerned about,
uh,
what the longterm costs might be to manage
that waste and also what the longterm
costs might be associated with
decommissioning the plant.
So the Pacific gas and
electric company argued that a,
the congression congressional intent
intent to preempt state regulation of the
nuclear industry was implicit
in the Atomic Energy Act.
A cell,
again,
preemption is a critical,
a legal tool,
uh,
that,
the industry relied upon
in order to a claim that a,
the state of California did not have
authority to create this moratorium.
So the Supreme Court
eventually ruled on this case.
And it's finding is quite interesting.
Uh,
the federal government possesses exclusive
with regulatory regulatory authority
over construction and operation of
nuclear facilities and over radiological
safety.
And the states hold authority
over decisions concerning
the need for additional
generating facilities,
licensing rate,
making,
land use and planning.
And the Supreme Court argue that federal
law would preempt the moratorium if it
was related to safety concerns.
So that's an interesting idea.
The federal government,
uh,
would be the expert,
experts in the area of risk assessment
and environmental assessment.
Thank you.
Emily.
Jack Scott,
you seem to be,
had been quite successful.
Persuasive.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
if it's related to safety concerns,
the court argued that,
uh,
California did not have the authority
to establish a moratorium because it was
worried about the health effects
or environmental dangers,
but it concluded the federal law would
not preempt a moratorium if California,
his logic was based on economics.
Uh,
so if they were worried about
cost considerations down the road.
So a very interesting distinction,
uh,
that,
allowed this moratorium,
uh,
to,
sustain a California,
his assertion that the legislature
at an act of the moratorium,
a moratorium based upon the
economic concerns was eventually,
uh,
accepted.
So that,
uh,
the nuclear waste policy
act of 1982 is important,
uh,
because most nuclear waste had
been and is now being stored,
uh,
in or nearby nuclear power plants.
So it's highly dispersed
around the country.
Uh,
think back on the u s map that I showed
you where the different dots of the
location of plants,
that's where the nuclear,
uh,
spent fuel.
The fuel rods that are
highly radioactive active,
uh,
are being stored within Connecticut.
This would include the,
a Haddam neck nuclear power
plant that's now been closed,
uh,
that's about 20 miles from a Yale,
to the east.
And it would also include
the three millstone plants,
uh,
over a Niantic.
So that,
uh,
under this statute,
the Department of Energy was granted the,
uh,
authority,
to begin to centralize a nuclear
fuel reprocessing and a repository.
So basically just a,
a,
a storage facility where this,
this waste could be handled
until it might be a reprocessed.
They run open and able to open
the facility and by an amendment,
uh,
the,
site at Yucca Mountain was,
it was established by a doe,
a to be the single repository.
So you can imagine that if
you were the state of Nevada,
you probably would not
be too happy about that.
Uh,
but if you are the state of California,
Connecticut,
or any other state that
had nuclear power plants,
uh,
you'd be really happy about the prospect
of getting rid of the waste that's
sitting inside your,
your a state boundary.
So this prompted a,
uh,
a lot of literally litigation,
litigation on the partner in Nevada,
uh,
that,
did not want the repository
to be located there.
Uh,
and litigation on the
part of other states,
including the state of Washington,
most recently arguing that they
wanted their ways taken to this,
this power plant.
And that,
uh,
the Obama administration did not
have the right to decide that,
uh,
this,
process,
uh,
the storage facilities should not open a,
when one thinks about the location
of either the plants or the storage
facilities,
you need to think carefully
about evacuation requirements.
Uh,
so before the Three Mile Island
accident in Pennsylvania,
the emergency response plans,
uh,
by nuclear power plants in
the U S we're voluntary.
That's quite striking.
Uh,
given what a,
the Atomic Energy Commission,
uh,
and the Nuclear Regulatory Commission
understood about the potential for these
new clients to,
to move,
uh,
over long distances being
transported in the air.
Now the,
uh,
the plans have to cover a 10 mile radius.
Now think about that 10 miles.
Would that be sufficient?
Well,
we're about 20 miles from the
nearest nuclear power plant here.
Uh,
but if you think about the Indian point
nuclear power plant outside of New York
City,
uh,
then you,
you need to think about the capacity
to move tens of millions of people,
uh,
away from a zone that would likely be
highly contaminated in the event of a
meltdown or an explosion or a serious
fire such as existed at three mile island
or a Chernobyl.
So the nuclear facility prompted,
uh,
Governor Pataki to commission a report
to evaluate the evacuation plan,
uh,
and criticized the communication
between local agencies,
the size of the area that affected
that would be effected by a release,
uh,
and the plans premises that
are not orderly evacuation,
uh,
rather than mass panic would likely.
And Sue,
it's kind of interesting because
if you drive around Connecticut,
uh,
within 10 miles of the
nuclear power plants,
occasionally you'll,
you'll see a sign on the side of the road,
sometimes very rural roads,
uh,
that,
notify the public that this is
part of an evacuation route,
uh,
in the event of,
of a,
a nuclear accident.
So that,
uh,
the capacity to,
to move people away from a contaminated
zone to be able to predict,
well,
how that zone might vary
given weather patterns,
it really is quite limited.
Uh,
also there was no consideration of the
probability or a likelihood of a tour or
a terrorist attack at these plants.
And,
uh,
this raised the,
a,
the possibility that,
that,
uh,
there ought to be aerial surveillance,
that,
uh,
there,
there ought to be planes that are flying
nearby these nuclear power plants as
there.
There was,
uh,
shortly after the nine 11
terrorist attack in New York,
so that the commission,
uh,
reported that any plant adjacent to high
population area should have different
requirements than plants
otherwise situated.
Uh,
because protective actions
are more difficult and the
consequences of failure or
delay or higher,
and the planning problems are more
serious because of the large population
concentrations.
So,
you know,
jump ahead here.
But the core problem associated with
waste is a radioactive halflife.
Uh,
and the,
the,
uh,
key concern is over
plutonium and there are 270,
uh,
tons of,
of separated plutonium from reprocessing
a of a fuel rods around the world that
now are sitting at sites,
uh,
and being stored.
And it has a half life
of roughly 24,000 years.
So when engineers and a safety experts,
we're thinking about the problem
posed by a Yucca Mountain,
uh,
this is the mountain in Nevada,
where the,
the storage facility,
uh,
has been partially constructed using
about $9 billion of taxpayers' money.
Uh,
so that the,
the,
the problem really here was how do
you ensure the integrity of a storage
facility for nearly a million years.
Uh,
and the,
uh,
they chose this site
because of its remoteness.
Poor Nevada member of Nevada was also
the site of the atmospheric weapons
testing,
a facility,
the largest and most
often used in the u s uh,
and they designed a machine
that would bore into the Rock,
uh,
and,
create a,
a,
uh,
tunnel within which,
either,
uh,
canisters would be
stored as dry fuel or a,
they could be stored in water.
So the,
the fuel is highly radioactive and
it's cooled and pools of water,
uh,
or in these dry casks.
And,
uh,
it's currently stored at
66 sites in the u s uh,
this is what one of the storage
facilities might look like in that,
to honeycombed,
uh,
set of boxes that you can barely see
in the bottom of the pool over here.
Uh,
that's how they store the,
uh,
the fuel rods.
So side by side,
by the way,
it also creates a radioactive water,
uh,
so that the amount of liquid waste that
is contaminated is far larger and volume
than,
uh,
the amount of,
of waste that is either low
level or high level waste.
So it was also curious that,
uh,
if you're projecting out a risk management
strategy over tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of years,
you know,
what happens if something occurs and a
society no longer speaks a language that,
uh,
is,
is understood today.
Uh,
you know,
what if a,
uh,
some massive accident occurred,
nuclear war,
whatever it,
whatever it is,
uh,
that,
leads,
uh,
whatever society exists that
stumbles across this plant,
uh,
to recognize it.
Kind of interesting.
It was a,
a,
in a way it was a labeling issue.
Uh,
how do you,
how do you communicate risks?
Uh,
not using a language but
using symbols instead.
So,
uh,
the Department of Energy Commission to
anthropologists to think about different
forms of symbolism and they
went back and looked at at,
uh,
what symbols,
would,
uh,
best,
convey the idea that there was
something extremely dangerous nearby,
uh,
or to stay away.
And,
uh,
the symbolism,
that,
uh,
is chosen is not represented here.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
the nuclear symbols that you see in the
upper right hand side of this slide are
those that are commonly used,
uh,
by the nuclear industry.
Uh,
but you can imagine that if you'd never,
uh,
if you did not know the culture today,
if you'd never seen any,
any assemble on,
on the side of a truck,
for example,
sometimes trucks have some
of these symbols that you
wouldn't have any idea with
what this meant.
The symbols on the lower
right are symbols that,
that are,
are commonly applied,
uh,
for industrial and worker safety,
situations.
Uh,
where as a symbol on the,
on the left is,
uh,
several,
several hundred years old.
So that a,
I mentioned a lawsuit
this most recent lawsuit,
uh,
this year,
the spring by Washington state
versus the Department of Energy was,
uh,
designed to encourage the federal
government to keep the Yucca mountain
repository viable.
So the Attorney General Mckenna,
uh,
made the right decision to file
this lawsuit today to stop the Obama
Administration from closing
down Yucca Mountain.
Now,
another problem with nuclear power is,
uh,
the potential for proliferation
of nuclear weapons.
So,
uh,
one might think that we need to think
about an international strategy,
uh,
to control the distribution of,
of nuclear fuel.
So a nuclear,
uh,
processed,
nuclear fuel could be further enrich to,
to,
uh,
form a weapon grade,
that,
uh,
could,
could produce nuclear weapons.
So the International Atomic Energy Agency,
uh,
and several other,
private organizations banded together to,
to,
uh,
encourage the creation
of a nuclear fuel bank,
uh,
so that the ga has been proposed to,
to constitute this bank and be responsible
for the dissemination of nuclear
fuel.
And then four,
it's a recovery once it's spent,
uh,
in this way,
they would have a collaborative,
uh,
attempt to try to,
to,
uh,
manage,
the fuel.
Uh,
thinking also about the MIT faculties
conclusions regarding safety.
Uh,
they ended their report saying that
parallel with improved operations,
uh,
the safety record of the nuclear industry
has really been quite remarkable in
the last 20 years.
Uh,
and that plays the nuclear power industry
displays by far the highest capacity
factor among all generation technologies,
providing now about 20% of the
u s elect a electrical supply.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
that the belief is that the,
the,
uh,
most reactors,
particularly the latest
generation reactors have the
capacity to operate safely,
uh,
that the,
the probability of bringing them online
in a way that would make a significant
difference,
uh,
in,
in the world with respect to,
to,
uh,
affects of,
energy consumption or climate change is,
is really quite limited.
So that,
uh,
with respect to the enrichment problem,
for example,
uranium when it's mind,
uh,
is a approximately 0.7%,
a uranium two 35,
but it needs to,
to,
uh,
have that increased to four to 5%
in order for it to be a usable,
as,
as fuel in a nuclear power plant,
uh,
compared to 20%,
that it has to be for a nuclear devices.
Now,
the Three Mile Island,
uh,
example in 1979 created a,
quite a,
uh,
a bit of alarm in the United States.
Uh,
and it was also a time when a movie
came out called the China Syndrome.
Uh,
that dramatized,
uh,
the,
effects of,
of a nuclear accident in an urban area.
And the nuclear,
uh,
facility at Three Mile Island,
I experienced what was
about a 60% meltdown.
And,
you know,
like most major accidents,
whether or not it's the,
uh,
the space shuttle blew up or the,
the,
uh,
Bhopal incident in India where a testimate
to that more than a hundred thousand
people were killed in a,
in a chemical plant explosion,
uh,
or,
or ensure noble.
Uh,
many people think about
the problem being assigned,
uh,
to and,
cause by technical failure,
a technology failure,
uh,
the hardware failure,
when in,
it's almost always human failure,
human failure to monitor
equipment effectively.
And that was certainly the case at three
mile island when a worker's mistook the
need to open a valve to allow cooling
water to go in and a cool down the fuel
rods that were,
were heating up.
So both Paul,
it was a problem of gauges with
the space shuttle blowing up.
It was a problem of,
of Miss Recognizing the,
uh,
the heat shield tiles that had fallen off,
and that,
uh,
we're highly temperature sensitive
so that the shuttle took off during a
temperature conditions that,
uh,
some recognized,
made a dangerous.
So the,
Eh,
the case history that is most important,
I think for us to think about,
uh,
which caused the greatest
amount of environmental damage,
uh,
in history were with respect
to a nuclear power plant,
uh,
occurred at the Chernobyl
plant in Pripyat.
Uh,
then the,
uh,
Soviet,
then within the Soviet Union.
And,
uh,
this occurred in April of 1986 and a
occurred during a yearly maintenance
operation,
uh,
where they were pursuing a
gradual power reduction and a,
they basically lost control of their,
of their maintenance efforts.
And the control rods
were removed to quickly.
Uh,
and then the power shot,
uh,
back down to low and,
and the,
uh,
water and the plant,
was,
uh,
turned in improper direction.
Uh,
the workers were confused
about what to do.
Uh,
the power surge 1500 times,
uh,
it's safe level within five seconds.
And a steel shield on
the roof of the building,
uh,
was blown into the sky and a,
the entire facility caught fire
for a period of several weeks.
So four days later,
after the Soviet Union had
maintained their silence,
uh,
the government announced an accident has
occurred at the Trenoble atomic power
station.
One of the nuclear
reactors has been damaged.
Measures are being taken to eliminate
the consequences of the accident.
Eight is being given to the victims
and the government commission has been
established.
So anyone who knows anything
about industrial accidents
or nuclear power plants
would recognize that,
that,
uh,
being able to warn the public,
immediately after an accident,
uh,
was exceptionally important.
The only nuclear,
uh,
event that,
this could be compared
to was one at Windscale.
Now known as tele field in the
northern part of Great Britain,
where in the 1956,
uh,
there was a fire in the plant,
and a significant amount of radiation
was released into the air and the workers
of the plant went out and commandeered
the tractors and cars of farmers that
lived in the surrounding area.
And the farmers were standing in their
field watching these workers basically
drive away in a,
in a caravan as quickly as they could,
uh,
so that,
they could reduce their exposure.
Again,
no government warning,
uh,
no,
attempts to evacuate the area.
Uh,
so that,
that,
uh,
the failure to take action,
soon after an accident like this,
uh,
results in the population
being exposed at the highest,
uh,
at the highest levels.
So the Soviets then disclosed a
certain leak of radioactive substances,
uh,
and then finally told the public
that a 200 people were hospitalized,
uh,
but the water in the
year in Kiev were safe.
They were reassuring the public.
In fact,
at the same time that they were air
force was seeding the clouds in the area
trying to induce a rain so that it could
wash the radiation from the sky before
it reached the,
the,
uh,
Soviet,
the Russian state.
And also to protect the,
uh,
the a reservoir,
that,
uh,
is,
to the south of,
or to excuse me,
to the north of Kiev.
So finally,
uh,
President Gorbachev and 86 came
on the news one evening and said,
good evening comrades.
All of you know that there's
been an incredible misfortune.
The accident at the Chernobyl plant as
his painfully affected the Soviet people
in shock,
the international community.
And for the first time,
we confront the real force
of nuclear energy out of,
out of control.
There are a variety of different
stories and lessons here,
but perhaps the,
uh,
one that is,
most sad is the way that
a workers were mistreated.
Uh,
the affects of,
of,
uh,
being exposed to radiation,
in the absence of protective gear,
uh,
was very well known to the Atomic
Energy Commission into the Soviet,
uh,
scientific experts from their
experiences with nuclear weapons.
But other than potassium
iodide pills and a,
the normal kind of a,
uh,
a suit than a,
a,
a fire men might wear as protective gear.
They were left helpless even
though they were told to a,
to go in and,
and try to put out the flames,
uh,
of the,
burning,
uh,
and charring fuel rods.
So also,
uh,
the s the Soviets and others,
misunderstood the pattern of distribution,
other radionuclides once
they reach the atmosphere.
So here you see,
April 26th,
uh,
the White,
that you see in the right
hand side of the upper left,
uh,
air photo here is demonstrating
the direction of the plume,
uh,
by,
April 28,
the plume,
it reached up over Norway,
Sweden,
and Finland.
Uh,
by April 30th.
you can tell that the,
the plume was being dispersed and being
blown back around northern Europe.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
eventually by May 6th,
uh,
it had scattered itself
pretty much all over Europe,
uh,
with a patchy kind of a concentration.
And you remember the surprise on the
part of the Atomic Energy Commission,
uh,
to the patchiness of the fallout,
you know,
finding a,
a high levels of strontium 90,
and in New York and Connecticut,
uh,
when the,
the cloud intersected a rainstorm.
And this affected us a,
a fallout pattern that was really
quite similarly a nonuniform,
uh,
in Europe.
And it took roughly about 10 days for
this plume to make its way all the way
around the world,
uh,
moving across China and then the Pacific
Ocean to reach the United States,
uh,
when it became detectable
in the milk supplies in a,
in the states such as Utah
and Arizona and in California.
So that,
uh,
the sensors that existed,
at that point in time,
we're picking up contaminants eventually
distributed around the United States
and eventually the rest of the world.
So as you look at this map,
you see a,
uh,
a,
radiation deposition,
a gradient from lightest
color to darkest color.
And a what's so striking about it is
that you see the patchiness demonstrated
here where you have a significant
deposition in Austria,
uh,
a significant deposition and Finland
and up in both Norway and in Sweden.
And the distance by the way,
uh,
is probably about six to 700 miles,
maybe about 800 miles from,
uh,
Chernobyl up to,
to a northern Europe.
So one thing that this did was it created
a complete chaos in a European food
markets.
So,
uh,
if it reached the ground it was
getting into the food supply,
while they realize that the
different nations all had separate,
uh,
radiation standards so that they,
they did not have a uniform
regulatory system to,
to protect against a one
nation selling a one commodity,
uh,
that,
has had a radiation level
that might not receive,
that might not be accepted by a another
nation that had a tougher standard.
Also,
uh,
the,
detection process.
You can imagine that,
uh,
the government was slow to
go out and try to figure out,
uh,
this patchiness with precision and that
had tremendous implications for the
period of exposure by the population.
So here's a good example of,
uh,
of,
the distributional pattern as it was
being recognized by the Soviet Union back
in the late 1980s.
And as they tested more,
uh,
they found more so that this map was
constantly changing in response to,
to a more rigorous testing.
So that the different
zones that you see here,
uh,
are designated as confiscated areas,
permanent control areas,
uh,
period control areas
and unregulated areas.
So that the,
uh,
the darkest red,
are the confiscated areas so that a lands,
agricultural lands,
urban lands,
uh,
homes,
residential communities,
uh,
commercial areas,
we're literally confiscated so that a
hundreds of thousands of people were moved
off of their land because the soils,
uh,
the plants,
as well as the building materials and
even the vehicles were contaminated.
Hundreds of thousands of vehicles,
uh,
turned into hazardous waste,
almost a within a matter of days.
So what to do with this area.
What do you do with people that you're
going to pull out of their homes?
Well,
they had to build new communities and
in some instances they even built new
communities in areas that
were contaminated because
they hadn't tested carefully
enough.
Kind of interesting because it should
ring bells with you with respect to the
Bikini island history where the Bikinians
were allowed to move back into an area
that the government supplied a
funds for constructing new homes.
And then they went in and tested that
more carefully and found that they had to
move out.
So that the tension here is that the
government will want to limit its own
liability,
its own costs for evacuating or for
dealing with hazardous waste or for,
for,
uh,
rebuilding a community.
So it has very little incentive
to disclose with precision,
the intensity of,
of,
uh,
of the concentrations.
So in this case,
uh,
the precision grew in response to
international pressure because they were
finding an Apache year,
the Apache,
uh,
highly contaminated areas,
in many different,
uh,
European communities.
And those different countries wanted to
have international authority to take the
Soviet Union to court so that they
could be compensated for their losses as
well.
The construction workers that we're
trying to put out the fire and then deal
with the,
uh,
the contaminated areas,
would drive vehicles in a,
whether they were aircraft,
whether or not they were,
they were,
uh,
cars or trucks such as this.
Uh,
the workers eventually were suited up
in protective gear and they had to wash
down the vehicles as they left the site
to keep the vehicles from tracking the
radionuclides different parts of,
of,
uh,
the effected area.
I mentioned that agricultural
lands were obviously affected,
uh,
especially those within the red
zones on the map that you just saw.
What do you do with
contaminated lands like this?
Well,
you basically have to scrape the surface
off of it and figure out how you're
going to bury the
contaminated material so that,
uh,
think about this,
76,000 square kilometers
of contaminated land.
And what about,
uh,
the forest plans?
What would happen to the timber that,
uh,
we're growing in the area?
Well,
they also absorb the radionuclides.
And many of those trees
are still standing.
Uh,
and many people would cut
down the contaminated trees,
cut the timber,
uh,
saw it up,
turn it into building material,
and people would build their houses of it.
It was a similar analogy to
the way that the uranium mines,
uh,
created that,
created,
uh,
the,
the fuel,
uh,
for,
the power plants,
uh,
the way that those minds,
left a waste of uranium mine tailings.
Uh,
so what do they do with that?
Well,
in,
in some instances,
they use the mine tailings as a
construction material for homes,
uh,
and,
particularly on native
American reservations.
So there's a,
a on a very unhappy and a
costly history of how Navajo's,
uh,
we're,
we're living in homes
that were built from,
from,
uh,
cement products that contained a uranium.
So that,
uh,
the,
the enormity of,
of,
uh,
the,
the effect of the contamination,
uh,
was just a beyond anybody's expectation,
cars,
trucks,
tanks had to be buried.
Uh,
and there are many stories about
how cars would be buried at night.
They'd be dug up before dawn,
uh,
and,
parts from those cars would then be
removed and sold on the black market.
So you all know that,
uh,
there's a very robust
used car part market,
uh,
virtually everywhere in the world.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
these,
these radioactive a used parts,
uh,
were brought back,
recycled back into circulation in Sweden.
It's interesting because the
Swedes found out about this book,
not because they were notified by
the Soviets or any other nation,
uh,
but because their workers showed up
at their nuclear power plants and they
started setting off alarms so that the
power plants in Sweden were shutdown one
after another,
but not because there was
a problem at their plant,
but because the workers were walking
in the door to the plant in the morning
and,
uh,
they had picked up the radionuclides
that have been deposited on the,
on the streets or the sidewalks,
uh,
in a,
in,
in Sweden.
And,
uh,
that contamination had set off the alarms.
And that's when they started looking at
weather patterns and trying to figure
out what the source might be.
There was no evidence that a nuclear
weapon had been at detonated a.
So they started looking at the location
and nuclear power plants and were able
to piece together the,
uh,
the weather pattern over
the past several days,
uh,
to pinpoint the Trenoble plant so that,
within,
within several days,
the radiation in Sweden was a thousand
times higher than it a previous
previously had been.
So I'm going to jump ahead here to,
uh,
discussion about evacuation.
A civil defense officials were finally
able to convince the government and plan
officials,
uh,
of the need to,
to evacuate areas,
areas that were closest to the plant.
Uh,
but 36 hours had passed.
And,
uh,
these are,
if you look at the,
uh,
the,
the current charts about,
uh,
the,
the periodicity of
release of the radiation,
you find that this first 36 hours a was
a crucial period when that population
should,
it should not have been allowed
to stay in the area so that,
uh,
they,
they really had no,
they had no plan.
The government eventually was able to
put together a thousand buses and picked
up first the children and then move
them a hundreds of miles away to,
uh,
to different camps.
So,
I mean,
as they studied the,
uh,
the,
the pattern of deposition,
they found that their evacuation
zone had been defined too narrowly.
So the evacuation zone,
uh,
had to be continually expanded so that,
by May 3rd,
this was,
uh,
only,
about,
uh,
six or seven days later,
45,000 residents had been evacuated
from a 10 kilometer radius.
Eventually a 210,000 people were
resettled into a less contaminated areas.
By the way,
if you take the United States requirement
that every nuclear power plant in our
nation,
I have a,
uh,
an evacuation plan that would cover an
area that is defined by a 10 mile radius.
And you compare it to the,
the movement of contamination
from this plant.
Uh,
you can see the 10 mile radius
in green here compared to the,
the,
uh,
eventual location of the,
deep red colored confiscation zones.
Uh,
I'm more than a hundred miles away,
so I'm going to jump ahead here
because I'm going to run out of time.
The safety,
uh,
regulations vary,
quite,
uh,
highly among the different nations,
leading to a chaotic set of bands.
Uh,
so that finally the
Europeans decided to ban,
meet live animals and produce from,
uh,
all areas within a thousand kilometers of,
of the site.
Uh,
the economic consequences were
enormous so that the Australia Austrian
government banned the
import of east block milk,
fruit and vegetables.
The Dutch agricultural ministry
prohibited cattle grazing.
The Swiss warned against providing
fresh milk to young children.
Italy ban the sale of
its own leafy vegetables.
And,
uh,
even the u s,
was warning people not to go to several
European nations because of the extent
of the contamination.
So the economic consequences just
associated with the food supply,
uh,
and it's contamination,
were far higher than anybody imagined.
There's also a,
a sad story about,
uh,
the same,
indigenous group in northern
Sweden that have long relied upon,
uh,
the,
livestock of a reindeer and a
reindeer feed on Moss and Lichen.
And,
uh,
the radionuclides built up,
heavily and the Moss and Lichen
and were detectable in their meat,
uh,
within a matter of several
days following the accident.
So that,
uh,
the Swedish government decided
that it was going to ban the,
the,
uh,
the sale of all future products,
from these animals except for,
uh,
the sale of fors.
So to,
to come to a conclusion here,
I want you to,
you'll be able to study this slide,
uh,
not from a,
this lecture,
uh,
but upon the classes server,
so that,
uh,
if you think about the relative amount of,
of,
uh,
radioactivity that was released by
the first atomic bombs and curious,
you see the,
uh,
first atomic bombs up here on the top and
Nagasaki and Hiroshima having released
about 250,000 curies,
uh,
from atomic weapons testing.
Totally during that period.
The,
uh,
the atmospheric weapons testing,
those figures are given here.
But then if you look
down here at Chernobyl,
uh,
you find that the estimates of exposure,
and,
and the estimates of those
exposed are really quite,
uh,
amazing.
17,400,
uh,
fatal cancers were expected.
A mode 2.9 billion people exposed.
So more than half of the
world's population was
exposed to fall out from this
nuclear power plant explosion,
uh,
with,
a very serious estimate of a fatal
cancer outcomes compared to the atomic
weapons testing program.
Where among everybody,
uh,
at the time this report was done back
in the 1990s by the national cancer
institute,
everybody in the world was
anticipated to have been exposed,
but only 12,000,
uh,
fatal cancers were expected
from that entire program.
So that the,
the magnitude of exposure,
the magnitude of risk is associated with,
with,
uh,
this kind of a failure,
has long been a underestimated.
Let me leave you,
uh,
at this,
time with one other thought because I
opened the lecture saying that we're
facing a very difficult decision
among how to allocate our,
our,
uh,
resources and investments
in different kinds of fuels.
Uh,
and I want you to think too about the
relative risk associated with coal fired
power plants.
Uh,
we don't have too much
time to talk about coal,
but coal produces a,
not just a sulfur and nitrogen
oxides produces particulates,
uh,
and particulates
particularly in combination,
particularly,
sorry,
particularly particularly
it's in combination,
uh,
with the sulfates,
pose a very serious health threat.
And many people don't realize that between
20,000 and 60,000 premature deaths in
the United States alone every year are
now attributable to coal fired power
plants on a world scale.
And the number is far more significant.
So these are deaths that
are premature deaths,
particularly among,
uh,
those that have a background
conditions of cardiovascular illness,
uh,
or,
other kinds of a respiratory illnesses.
So that premature deaths from this form
of energy are far higher than it ever
been.
A counted for,
uh,
with respect to the nuclear industry,
so that the,
uh,
coal has,
this image of being a,
a relatively safe fuel
compared to nuclear power.
Uh,
but I'm hoping to get you to,
to rethink that.
Uh,
the nuclear waste issue I think is
an overwhelmingly persuasive to me,
uh,
that the nuclear industry,
should not be seriously encouraged.
And,
uh,
I,
am disappointed and a surprise by
the Obama administration support,
uh,
that came out to just a few,
a few weeks ago for it.
Uh,
and on next Tuesday we'll be talking
about the future of renewables in
particularly the different kinds of
legal strategies that have been employed,
uh,
including tax strategies,
different subsidies,
uh,
different kinds of credit systems,
in order to,
to,
uh,
try to,
increase,
uh,
human investment in,
in,
uh,
renewable sources.
So a,
have a great weekend
and enjoy the weather.